[Music]
thanks for joining us America it's a
free call a triple eight eight two five
five two two five Peter is with us in
Charleston South Carolina i Peter how
are you hi there thanks for taking my
call hello I I am recently married about
five months ago I got married and we
came into the math thank you we came
into the marriage with $5,000 credit
card a $10,000 credit card both on me
and then seventy thousand dollars in
student debt now we use our wedding
money and tax refund to pay off the five
thousand dollar credit card good and
then we had about ten thousand dollars
saved up and we were just about to put
that down for a down payment on a house
and then at the last moment it killed us
but we instead paid off the other credit
card which was the right citizen but you
know obviously it hurt and so recently
now we've really started to try to
attack the student debt good and we've
been using me every dollar budget app to
do that good now we currently live in a
one-bedroom apartment and again we were
about to buy a house but we didn't so we
read up to one more year on our
apartment and it's you know I
it's horrible living in this apartment
but you know I do want to get out but
you know but we're willing to go another
year and so my question is you know at
what point should we be looking to maybe
start saving for a down payment on a
house is it once we finally pay it off
all of the student loan or should it be
a little bit earlier because you know I
look at we bring in our gross incomes
118 thousand our Nets about eighty and
so we're putting half of our monthly
income towards the student debt which is
about three thousand dollars cut out a
lot already and even doing that it's
going to take twenty four months to
fully pay this off and then you know
after that twenty four months we won't
have any money for a down payment yet so
we'll have to go another full year and
you know three years and the single
bedroom apartments just kind of you know
a very
a feeling that doesn't feel too good how
old are you I'm 20 I'll be 24 and in a
few days and she's 25
okay the the 38 year old version of you
will be very happy with the 27 year old
version of you that saved up and with
student loan debt free and then saved up
and bought a house it feels like crap
now but three years of the scope of your
life is not much you're gonna be fine
this is how people that are mature do
things adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good if you
want to change rentals that's fine but
don't buy a home until you get the
student loan paid off why are you only
taking home a D if you make a hundred
and twenty you pick on me because I'm
receiving for retirement I have a stop
or I'm I mean stop it okay alright
you're trying to do three or four things
at one time you're in a hurry
okay and what we found that for 30 years
of teaching people how to handle money
the people that went with money focus on
one thing and killing then they move to
the next thing and kill it then they
move to the next thing and kill it and
that's the ones that win when you try to
do six things at once it ends up nothing
gets done because all of your
mathematical power gets diluted I also
suspect that you're that you've probably
over withholding I think you got too
much coming out your check for taxes I
personal I think I might I I think I
come out as out a little bit more too
much withholding it and she comes a
little bit under but because I make more
I think it does wind up we do get a
pretty sizable tax refund a sizable tax
refunds means you're over withholding
okay that's the definition up one more
allowance on that okay well no more than
that what was your tax reform tax reform
last year was about five thousand
dollars but I had a pretty good few
credits to go along with it and because
I was single for most of the year and
then got married at the end I was able
to claim married for the whole year so
mm-hmm
that had a pretty good view
okay so what you may want to do because
everything's new in your tax situation
because now you're married and you have
the combined income and you'll be doing
married filing jointly you may want to
sit down with the tax pro and actually
calculate what your taxes will be for
eighteen and let's adjust your
withholding to that amount I think
you're over withholding in excess of
$5,000 is what I think I'm hearing okay
as a couple as a couple right now okay
right and so because 118 should not be
80 take-home pay even with a 401 K
deduction right it's too far down that's
the math I'm doing and done this a
couple times so anyway that that that's
I think what we're going to do is bring
home another $20,000 a year with this
discussion you and I are having okay
that'll change things a lot yeah there
we go I see and a customer 100% focusing
on kicking Sally maze but there's not
room for that woman in a one-bedroom
apartment she's got to go knock her butt
in the street she gets her eviction
notice because I want you out of that
apartment as bad as you want out of the
apartment then we're going to build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses maybe fifteen grand in your
case just for rainy days then you save
up your down payment and you're gonna do
all of that in under thirty six months
but I don't know how far under it's
probably going to be between 24 and 36
months then when you buy a home you got
no payments in the world you got 15
grand in the bank when you move in and
Murphy will not move in your spare
bedroom if you buy a home while you're
broke all crap is gonna break loose
everything that can go wrong will your
life will look like a country song you
are inviting trouble and that's how life
works man it is when you're broke you
invite trouble you know what I'm talking
about
yep absolutely seen it a few times
already I'm beyond but I've seen it yeah
I think you're sharp dude man what do
you do for a living okay I thought you
had a good mind you got good critical
thinking skills talking to you so good I
think you did a good job man so hang on
I'm gonna send you a copy of the book
the Total Money Makeover which is gonna
walk you through why I did what I did
here
and it gives you more than a radio
answer and since you're a software
developer you'll see the flow chart
you'll see the process that I'm doing
when you see the whole thing in a
holistic sense then it'll click and
you'll go oh okay he's not as crazy as I
thought he was okay awesome thank you so
much dad I appreciate it hang on Kelly
I'll pick up will send you the Total
Money Makeover